The new Pet Sematary has fans debating the
changes it made to the original story, but
what I've also discovered is there are some
radically different endings to the remake
that were almost used in the final film.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers I'm Jan and in
this video I'm revealing the three incredible
endings you never got to see in the new Pet
Sematary, including the happy ending Stephen
King recommended.
Plus keep watching for more deleted scenes
cut from the final film.
Spoilers ahead for the movie, so take care
if you haven't seen it yet.
The filmmakers of the new Pet Sematary had
three different endings planned for the movie
which they describe as dark, darker and darkest.
Now, the ending we actually got for the film
was pretty bleak with not just Ellie and Rachel
dying, but Louis also killed.
On top of that, in the movie's final scene
we see the resurrected Louis, Ellie and Rachel
approaching the family's sole survivor, Gage
who's in a car looking out the window at his
undead family when we hear the horrifying
sound of the doors unlocking.
The opening scene of the movie showed us an
opened car door with bloody hand stains heavily
indicating that poor Gage surely didn't survive.
This chilling everyone-dies twist on the original
story was the darkest version on the table,
and if you found it too horrifying for your
liking you might have preferred the much lighter
ending that Stephen King suggested.
The horror legend saw an "early cut" once
the filmmakers began their reshoots, and based
on that, he recommended "an ending where Gage
is walking up the middle of the road.
We see dawn, and we hear a truck coming, and
think, 'Oh my God, he's gonna get greased
in the road.
That's how this is gonna end!'
[…] Then at the last second, this woman
pulls him out of the road and rescues him,
and says, ‘Where's your mommy and daddy?'"
Both King's original story and the 1989 movie
had Gage rather than Ellie killed by a truck
in the road earlier in the story, so this
alternate ending would have been a hat tip
to that, with the twist being this time the
little toddler is saved… at least for the
time being.
King would have ended the movie right there,
leaving the ultimate fate of the woman and
Gage unknown as she goes off in search of
Gage's parents.
Speaking to EW, King suggested he's "a sucker
for a happy ending" and it's interesting that
the finale he suggested for the remake would
have been drastically different to how his
own book ended.
The second alternate ending was actually filmed
and while it's still dark, it's just a touch
lighter than what we saw in the final movie.
In an interview with Collider, producer Lorenzo
DiBonaventura describes what it entails.
"There's a version […] where mom and daughter
are both back from the dead.
And there's a shot of [Louis] with Gage in
his lap.
Both of them are normal.
[…]
And then, mom walks in.
She's clearly out there in another world.
And daughter comes in, and daughter says,
'Hi, mommy.
I love you.'
And then the camera's on them like a family
portrait.
And then it just pulls back, the little kid's
crying, and [Louis] just looks like he's been
run over by a bus."
So, in this version we still have an undead
Ellie and Rachel at the end, and although
it seems unlikely that Louis and Gage could
survive the onslaught of these two reanimated
family members, the way it ends does leave
open the slightest possibility.
This alternate ending is more of a direct
play on the original 1989 movie's ending where
Louis was waiting in the kitchen for the resurrected
corpse of Rachel to return to him.
In that movie, it showed Rachel grabbing a
knife and ended on Louis's screams which is
why I think this second alternate ending for
the new film very likely implies that Louis
and Gage will both die.
A 2017 draft of the screenplay also reveals
yet another interesting finale that could
have been.
In this ending, it's Rachel who discovers
Jud's dead body and then goes to look for
Ellie in the woods.
She finds her undead daughter in the Pet Sematary,
and armed with Jud's gun she tries to shoot
Ellie but misses.
Ellie attacks her mother with the scalpel
and during the fight Rachel drops the revolver.
Ellie grabs the gun, aims it at her mother
and with pitch black eyes and a wicked smile
on her face, she says "love you mommy", then
pulls the trigger.
But just at that moment Louis arrives, and
in the aftermath we discover he's the one
who's been shot.
Louis dies leaving Rachel stricken with grief.
The undead Ellie then walks over to her mother
and goes to kill her but notices something
about her mother's pain and instead whispers
something to her.
The scene then cuts to Gage [asleep] in the
car and suddenly Ellie's there smiling at
him.
Rachel then walks over, unlocks the car door
and takes Gage over to the front porch with
her where she sits down.
The camera pans out to Ellie dancing in the
yard, and a shadow appears in front of her.
Ellie looks up surprised and exclaims "Daddy!"
At which point the screen cuts to black.
So, as you can see, this ending like the others
is pretty crazy and twisted.
It's more open in terms of whether Rachel
and Gage could survive but, of course, they'd
need to defeat the resurrected Louis and Ellie.
Now, if you watched the trailers for the movie,
you'll probably have noticed quite a few scenes
missing from the final film.
For example, several Zelda scenes didn't make
it in, including this one of Zelda creeping
up behind Rachel and grabbing her.
Other Zelda scenes that were cut involve Rachel
experiencing more visions of her sister when
she visits her childhood home in Boston.
In an interview with SlashFilm, the directors
described a deleted scene where Rachel goes
to her sister's bedroom to confront her fear
of her dead sister in a moment similar to
one in the 1989 movie.
The reason for this cut was that the directors
"wanted to [...] focus the Zelda scenes" on
the house the family moved to in Ludlow as
by only having visions of Zelda appear to
Rachel in the family's new house, it emphasises
the power the Wendigo has on the area near
the cursed burial ground.
The filmmakers also said they didn't want
the Zelda storyline to overwhelm the film,
but they've promised that we'll see these
extra scenes on the home entertainment release.
Interestingly enough, though, Zelda wasn't
actually in the original script for the remake,
but when directors Kevin Kölsch & Dennis
Widmyer came on board, they insisted on including
Zelda's story as it was vital to give Rachel
a more substantial role.
There's another terrifying snippet in the
trailers that didn't make it in which looks
like a flashback to when Jud's wife Norma
was alive.
This scene could have been really interesting
as it could have helped explain why Ellie
tells Jud she's seen his dead wife Norma burning
in hell for what he did to her.
In King's original novel, the possessed Gage
taunts Jud about Norma cheating on him with
all his friends.
And in the book, Jud also had a brief history
of having visited prostitutes.
Kölsch has said that the deleted scene shows
"more of Jud's backstory, and his relationship
with the burial ground."
Which leads me to think that when Norma died,
Jud resurrected her, but as with everyone
who comes back Norma wasn't right.
You can see her here rocking back and forth
in a chair while an iron has been left on
in the background.
Jud probably had to kill the undead Norma
and now the Wendigo is using Ellie to come
back as his wife to punish him.
There are also some intriguing trailer scenes
of children in animal masks that never made
it into the final movie.
In the film, we only see the kids as they
parade down to the Pet Sematary, but, in the
trailer, there's also these additional scenes
of the children going beyond the barrier all
the way to the cursed burial ground where
they seem to be burying a dead animal.
The directors have revealed that these scenes
were only filmed for marketing the movie.
In their interview with SlashFilm, they explained
that "on studio films, they send marketing
departments down, and they actually have their
own camera unit, and they take your actors
and go shoot things that are just specifically
for trailers, and marketing spots."
In fact, the directors only saw those scenes
for the first time when they saw the trailer!
They were slightly concerned that these fake
scenes, so to speak, might confuse the audience
but, in the end, they don't think they did.
What do you think about any of these deleted
scenes and would you have preferred any of
the alternate endings?
Tap the screen to vote in the poll and leave
your thoughts in the comments below.
And if you enjoyed this, subscribe and hit
the bell to get all my new videos.
Next tap left for a full breakdown of Pet
Sematary including easter eggs, the Wendigo
and sequel possibilities, or tap right for
my horror movie deleted scenes playlist.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!